[Music]
here we look at the math behind an
animation like this one what's known as
a complex 4A series each little Vector
is rotating at some constant integer
frequency and when you add them together
tip to tail the final tip draws out some
shape over time by tweaking the initial
size and angle of each Vector we can
make it draw pretty much anything that
we want and here you'll see how this
particular animation has 300 rotating
arrows in total Go full screen for this
if you can the intricacy is worth it
when you consider the chaotic frenzy
that you're looking at and the Clockwork
rigidity underlying all the Motions it's
bizarre how the Swarm acts with a kind
of coordination to trace out some very
specific shape and unlike much of the
emergent complexity you find elsewhere
in nature this is something that we have
the math to describe and to control
completely just by tuning the starting
conditions nothing more we can make this
swarm conspire in all of the right ways
to draw anything that you want